good morning good morning so um yeah
thank you jed uh
as jud said we're basically gonna take a
quick look at some tips tricks and hacks
uh that you normally use on the web but
as viewed from within webkit right
so
this is kind of a culmination of a lot
of discussions we've had with people
over the past few years we've noticed
that they're doing certain things and
and realizing maybe like the engine can
kind of
do different modes
depending on like what you know kind of
little tips they use um but we realize
that a lot of people don't quite realize
what's happening inside the engine when
they do that um sometimes to bad effects
or sometimes a good effects
so it's basically a talk where we take a
few of the really popular ones that
we've seen where people seem to have a
lot of
misconceptions
or misunderstandings of what's going on
inside of the engine and we're going to
look into them to actually show you what
is going on
right so
so judd gave a little introduction
so again i'm matt uh and this is jing
and so we just left apple um earlier
this year and are starting our own
little company together um in the bay
area so
if you see us around you can talk to us
later more about that but we basically
worked together on the safari and webkit
team for the past few years
yeah that's what else so
um
so to start off um there are basically a
few uh demos that we had made to to kind
of illustrate the points of what these
tips tricks and hacks are that people
use
but we realize uh demos are kind of
boring right because if we could have
you know
synergy in our talk or whatever right
then uh then it'd be great because
everyone loves synergy so like let's
make a game out of these these these
tips tricks and hacks let's put them all
together in like one example um
that's fun to do so basically last night
we were kind of scrambling to do all
this and fit it all into one so we came
up with a little simple game uh that
we'd like to call vertifall and so um a
little play off the german word uh
verter which means words in german um
the simple game that we made was was
essentially um you might be
you see like these words falling from
the top of the page right so maybe like
chocolate cupcakes whatever
and your objective for the game is to go
through and type the words as fast as
you can so for everyone you type and you
get right
you get some points for that right so if
you type cupcakes really fast before it
hits the bottom of the page and
disappears then you get like eight
points or so um and so on and you're
kind of just you know going against the
clock see how fast you can type all the
words um
so that's a little fun little example
that kind of brings together all of our
all the things we want to talk about and
so we'll
so um we'll show you in a second uh what
the game looks like um
basically it's about like 2 a.m last
night right and um and we're totally
freaking out because we need to get this
all done before tomorrow uh
so we know that like there's only one
way we can possibly um you know get this
done in time uh because we need to meet
malte right at uh at the super awesome
raver club like five in the morning he's
talking about so
so it's like you know it's just it's
game time right we have 2 a.m until 5
a.m to get this done and then we have
all this like uh super partying at the
club until nine in the morning and then
breakfast now and if you have any clue
this is why we're so tired right now
this is this is a true story uh
so there's only one way we could
possibly do this in time right so we
know we need to get uh to ballmer's peak
right
so um
so to illustrate such a thing uh we're
gonna do that right now we go through
all right cheers this is true story
okay so this game that we're saying
right the the words are falling from the
sky as they should be right and we're
trying to type them as fast as possible
however we get it the game done
and all of a sudden it's it's not
working of course you know because we're
total noobs and so the very issue they
run into
the very first issue we see is that
got it is that all the words
um
are not there
are not there right they should be they
should be basically flowing from the top
um because we have a little transition
that's like you know
going from the top to the bottom and
then sliding them down however um it's
not working they like are stuck
somewhere right so we go to look at the
code for a second
and jingle explain what we're doing here
all right so basically in our code we
have these divs that have classes word
and what we want to do is start them off
at the top of the page above the top of
the page and then have them animate all
the way to the bottom
so what we did here was basically
have like call this function called this
batch word that creates a word element
inserts it into the dom and then changes
the top position to the height of the
screen
um so we're thinking about this last
night and we're like oh wait when people
on the web saying something about like
you need a set timeout zero be between
like inserting something into the dom
and changing its property or else like
the transition doesn't take effect or
something um so so we're like okay let's
try this um we changed our code to
basically do a set time at zero and then
um set the final top position
and then we're like okay let's try this
out see if it works
and it does
okay
so you know our game works we're well on
our way to partying and we're also
making our way steadily at bomber's peak
uh which means we got super distracted
who were like why do we even need a set
time at zero i mean we have like one css
value the next one why can't the browser
just do it
so we went online and we looked up the
definition of how transitions are
triggered in the spec
so
the w3c spec says when the computed
value of a property changes then then
the engine starts to transition
so we know a little bit about
how web browsers work so when you're
running your javascript code each chunk
of your code is actually run in a single
run loop
inside the browser and the browser kind
of like manages when to call these rom
loops and in between these run loops
then the browser does like whatever it
needs to do to actually um you know
render your page respond to system
events and anything that's not directly
in your control
so one of the things that the browser
does during this time between each round
loop is to update all the styles you've
set and layout so that makes sense
because when we have a set timeout zero
we're basically saying we're done with
the first round loop do whatever you
need to do in the browser and then and
then do whatever we said later
so that's why it works awesome
um okay so we're done with that and
we're like okay i want to go party we're
gonna go party let's try um playing this
game
huh
there's like this weird stutter when i
type so this is junk right this is too
slow for some reason every time we're
pressing one letter it's just absolutely
slowing down so this is not good either
right
all right um so i know that the
animation works fine and it only slows
down when i'm typing so it must be
something wrong with my event handler um
so i go look at my event handling code
and
this is the function i call basically
every time you type a letter um i go
through loops through all of the word
elements in the page and then compare
their inner text to see if it matches
the letter typed and if it does then
i'll just like change the class name
which sets some styles on it that
highlights it
um so as i'm looking at this i start
remembering um there's there's this talk
on youtube oh it's it's uh paul irish
has talked about
how accessing some values in the loop
could cause reflows and slow things down
actually now now i really remember it's
our inner text is one of these
properties that causes a reflow
so i think the tip was
to access all of your values at the same
time and then set your values at the
same time
so i changed my code and now i'm running
two loops the first loop gets all the
inner text and the second loop
just accesses a local variable instead
of asking for
for it from the element
so let's run that code
yay
now it's responsive so breaking out that
pattern so that we do all the all the
gets of the inner text and then all the
sets after right then we're avoiding all
of those reflows so
so now we see it's much smoother right
um
so of course yet again
so yet again since matt's still holding
my beer
we're you know nearly atop farmer's peak
and we're like you know why are we
causing these reflows i'm just asking
for some text from the dom
so we decided to actually just step
through this loop and look at what's
actually happening in webkit's c plus
code
so
i put a breakpoint inside inner text
and this is the function that i see
and you see that the first line there
says
um column document update layout ignore
pending style sheets super long name so
i'm like what does this thing actually
do and then i kept stepping through
stepping through i'll save you guys all
the pain of stepping through like 20
files
um but at the end it comes down to
calling recalc style on the document
so i go into recap sound and there's
this this is like this huge function
that's like three pages long
um and it does what it says it does it
recalculates the style if it needs to be
recalculated but the most interesting
part is that um near the end of it it
the element actually loops through all
of its children and it says if any of my
children needs its style recalculated
then i also had to recalculate my style
even if i didn't change
so i'm going through this loop asking
for inner text and going through all
this logic but i haven't changed
anything so this doesn't really trigger
anything okay let's see what i did next
so the next thing i did is i changed the
um the class name to something else
so again i go into web webkit and i see
that this function called class
attribute uh change got called and
there's a whole bunch of stuff it's
supposed to do but at the very very end
it says send me style recalc
which sounds like it might trigger the
thing which you saw earlier
so to help me organize my thoughts
i kind of graphed out what my dom looks
like so i have the document root
document
element and i have this game container
that contains a whole bunch of words and
i just went through the first word and
set it style so the first word has a
dirty bit for if the style needs to be
recalculated
so
now that i'm on to the next iteration of
my loop i'm looking at the second word
and i'm asking the second word for its
inner text
and
as you saw earlier when you ask for
inner text it triggers all these
function calls that go to recalc style
so the document asks do i need to
recalculate myself and it's like oh do
my children need to recalculate their
styles and the game says do my children
need to calculate their styles and the
first word says hey i need my style
recalculated
so the first word does its own layout
calculation things and it goes back to
the game and the game says well one of
my children had the style recalculated
so i guess i had to recalculate myself
too
so what this actually caused in my game
was that every single time i asked for
inner text the game element was relaying
out all of its words so if i had n words
i would have n loops and inside each
loop i would relay out inwards so it's
like exponentially expensive to have the
axises in the same loop as the setters
so
that explains why um i need to access
all the values first and then and then
send all the values
so
now our game is pretty much done
actually to capture that point there for
a second um you might ask yourself like
like why is
why does like the browser have to do all
this work why can't it be as smart as my
javascript loop could be just to like
cache those values essentially um and
that would get into a big discussion of
like if you look at the the way like
style resolution and everything works
inside of the browser it's it's
obviously a lot of really complicated
css rules all implemented right um so
there are definitely some places where
we can do that sort of thing we can
speed things up but in a day like we
don't really know like what you're going
to do next in javascript right so it's a
lot of cases where it's just not worth
it to possibly save around like every
intermediate you know intermediary value
between it um so basically the take-home
message there is like you just kind of
accept the fact that like this is the
current code so this is this is what you
have to deal with on the platform right
so so even the best things that can be
done in the future they currently don't
exist so it's just
you know limitation of the current
implementation basically
um but yeah okay so so we fixed that
right and we've
we've understood that one um but now
like uh
we're looking at it and and if you can
see like like keg is kind of just
shaking as it's falling down it doesn't
really look that smooth right and since
the perfectionist that we are we want
this game to be
really really smooth right so
so we get so we um
you know we remember this uh
we remember this um this tip that
someone told us before right uh that was
like use like translate z zero on
elements when you're animating them uh
because that like like
sets hardware acceleration to happen or
some such thing right so you can get
these awesome crisp animations
so um
so we recall this
and we're basically um we go to use this
this little hack because it sounds great
right so
so it boils down to before we had a
webkit transition you know on on top so
that it goes from you know top at zero
all the way down to the the height of
the page um but instead now we just
added uh webkit transform um with the
translate z initially zero uh and then
later we add translate z and translate y
so it goes down the page so same exact
effect just using transforms now as
opposed to using um a transition on the
top
and this is the trick that everyone uses
that should hopefully like hardware
accelerate my you know animation right
so let's check it out let's see if it
works
yeah so that's buttery smooth right
so this is the effect that everyone goes
for
and
it's
it's like the holy grail of making
awesome animations right um you can't
live without this if you're trying to do
this sort of thing it seems um but why
doesn't like the browser you know do
this on its own right um
like we're we're curious like what's
going on here so at this point of course
we're totally like a top bomber peak
right we are even like jumping over the
top of it high-fiving right we are so
curious about what goes on in the engine
um and so we start to
so we start to ask the questions right
like why doesn't the browser always do
this why don't i just always do it in my
page like every animation i do why don't
i just add like translate zero because
that would just make everything better
right um well not so fast right uh so
we start by looking into the engine and
seeing like what's going on
when our curiosity's getting better us
here and we realize that there's some
some some machinery being set up we're
now entering this thing called like
compositing mode right so webkit is
dropping into this code uh that it
wasn't in the case before when we were
transitioning just on the um on the top
element and so
so it seems to be entering this
compositing mode where it's setting up
all this machinery right it's creating
these like layer things and
you see a lot of code paths that are now
being used that are like if depth
between accelerated compositing
flags there so what like what is
compositing what is what is this
accelerated notion where is that
hardware acceleration coming into play
um
and whatever happened like talking about
hardware rendering
so to understand all these concepts um
we need to quickly just do a little
segue to give a graphics 101
to understand this concept of what's
going on with accelerated compositing so
in the next
uh
five
plus minutes i'm going to try to fly
through uh
rendering from top to bottom as to how
it works
especially in the lens of how it works
in a rendering engine such as webkit and
hopefully i trick you into understanding
how accelerated compositing works all
within
breaking neck time so so let's start so
so compositing and rendering are the two
different terms we're talking about here
right normally you hear people talking
about accelerated rendering but what
does that mean well rendering is the
overall process
of what we're doing here where
compositing is a substep of it so we
have to know what rendering is first we
can talk about compositing so
as it's defined rendering is generally
the process of taking a model and and
rendering it into an image so by an
image i mean like you know a bitmap
image or um you know an actual like 2d
array of pixels this just a little chunk
of memory in the end right
and your model uh in the case of
um webkit and a rendering engine for the
browser right
is just basically your dom plus css
so
um so your model is simply that dom that
you give us in the css and webkit does
the job of simply taking that and
translating that literally into an image
right and at the end of the day i'm
going to grossly oversimplify this um
but uh
let's say that that image at the end is
just called a frame we'll just use that
term for a second and we'll say that
once we've generated that frame all we
need to do is give it to the gpu uh and
my graphics computer graphics friends
are totally gonna kill me for
oversimplifying this so much but let's
just say simply the job of the gpu is to
take our frame that image that we give
it and it makes sure that it appears in
the screen okay
so
so cool so so we don't have to worry
about anything after we've generated
this image we just need to generate that
that like actual set of pixels right
so how might web kit go about doing this
process of rendering well a very simple
and naive approach
we'll go through in a second with a
simple example to see how we could do it
just in a very simple sense
so let's consider
a very simple uh
system where we have a say a small
screen and we have a very simple page
and so the page is about 20 by 20 pixels
um
and
on the body we just basically have one
color so one big color background
we have one child that's the square div
uh and it's just ten by ten
and it has one background color right
pink so there's like simple squares
going on here um and then in within the
square there's like a bunch of like
little divs we'll just call them little
js divs you'll see in a second that are
all just a bunch of little white
pixels essentially and it's going to
look something like this
so right so we have that that background
square and then you know the
uh it's cayenne and then
cyan and then we have this pink one and
then the white dots um so how might we
go about like creating this right if we
were just given that dom and and we need
to make it into this well the first step
may be to go through
and paint from uh back to front so we
would basically fill in the pixels of
this like frame thing right this image
one by one where we put in blue blue
blue and then eventually extrapolate and
go fill up the whole thing the next step
that we could do
is to go to that next child element that
second div that's square that's pink and
we fill in you know just fill in the
pixels boom boom boom the values and the
whole thing we're cursed again to the
children and we go through and fill in
all the for the j and the s
and that's that's pretty simple right
so
that's essentially what boils down to
the process of rendering that's pretty
simple naive approach of how to do it
um so let's think about for a second
like how many operations we were doing
to do it in this naive approach
basically we had that 20 by 20 square so
and then a 10 by 10 square and then 7x5
that we did on top of that so this
results in about 535
pixel fill operations so that's the kind
of like amount of time it would take to
generate every one of these frames right
but we know like the average screen goes
about at 60 frames per second
so multiply this out and we're looking
at for this tiny screen 32 000 uh
operations to do this per second right
so for the modern cpu this obviously no
problem to do however if you consider
like a much bigger case you can imagine
this can start to get uh really
expensive right so like a macbook air
screen where you have
900 by you know 1440.
now you're talking about a lot of
operations like just over you know close
to 2 million so that's simply just the
amount of time it takes to fill in these
pixels right um
but even worse uh
oh so right so that's the operation for
frame and like overall
you're looking at 102
you know million per second uh
operations you have to do for that so if
you consider like that an average system
is is doing a lot more things than just
rendering this is a lot of time to do
this naive approach if you have a lot of
different programs going on different
windows bunch of tabs open you're
talking about a lot of different people
doing this amount of work and that just
becomes too much it doesn't scale
and if you consider even worse
you're looking at about 600 megabits per
second like um
for just pushing this one set of frames
from from your screen over to the gpu
which is just a ton of data transfer we
can which just totally
bogged on the system right so
so basically this doesn't quite scale
right this uh this is not a good
approach we can't possibly make fast web
pages with this
so in comes the role of compositing
right so
so basically in that first approach
there we were we were just running
through and um
and kind of doing all rendering as like
one pass right
but compositing is this notion of of
breaking up the step of where you're
you're combining visual elements from
separate sources into like one source so
so we were kind of doing this implicitly
before when when we drew from back to
front we did like the the one color the
next color over top we were by the by
the method of drawing we were actually
implicitly compositing appropriately
so uh so instead let's break this up
into two different steps two discrete
steps right so the first one is drawing
and the second one is compositing like i
said um so in order to do this
we need to be able to take every element
and give it its own little section of
memory that it can do the drawing into
initially
and then we'll do the second step that
i'll explain in a second it's
compositing which is the process of
combining all of those separate images
into this one that we need to give over
to the gpu right
so
so let's start by looking at it we had
like that
uh
we have the three different we'll call
them layers so these are basically like
the little um like
off-screen kind of frames per element
that we're giving so our dom was pretty
simple we had that you know the body uh
we had the little pink layer um for that
that background div and then um
and then we have this js layer which is
just a bunch of those little divs that
um
were just the simply the white dots
right
so
so what we have here is um
is basically uh
these chunks of memory that we need to
draw in as our first step so we're going
to go and fill those in like before same
process we go through you know
the cyan dots and then
all the pink dots and then the js ones
and now that we have these layers we
need to do the second step which is
compositing so this is simply the
process of of taking the contents of the
one layer
and copying into the other
and instead of going back to front here
we're doing now front to back so we take
the like the foremost elements that
would be in the front of the page
um so the js an example here we take all
of those little divs that make up the
little js dots and we are literally
copying those into the pink one um so
that we composite it into
the pink one in the right location right
so simply just a copy
and then we copy that pink one into the
appropriate location we composite it
into the into the overall body and now
basically the layer of the body
finally has the contents inside of it
that we need to give over the gpu
so you may be asking yourself like
what's the point of this like we just
allocated a bunch more memory and did
just as much work but we
you know didn't gain anything
but you have to consider what happens
when things are happening first at a
larger scale you have a lot of things
you're drawing on your page and perhaps
you're even um you know adding effects
like if you scroll literally the
elements are moving around or you do an
effect like you just saw
that's a lot of if we were to do that
repaint every time we were literally uh
like in the old method of just simply
rendering in one pass we were redrawing
a frame like over and over and over and
i said before you know 600 megabits per
second like throughput to the gpu all of
that that was a lot of time so this
compositing path though
we can instead skip all that rendering
and compositing that we did for that
pink layer and we can just use the
contents of that layer and recompose it
into different locations in that
overall blue layer right that topmost
layer so that basically saves us a ton
of work every time we can go a bit
faster here
so obviously trade-offs
um we have allocated much more memory to
get some speed ups in how we do things
so of course memory is not
limitless you you definitely have
you know
a kind of a trade-off of how many layers
you should be allocating depending upon
you know how much performance you need
perhaps to like speed up the rendering
so it's important to remember this uh
now now keep in mind at this point the
talk we haven't yet talked about
hardware versus software we basically
everything we've been doing to like do
this rendering and this compositing this
drawing has all been happening you could
just do it in software like any program
could do this right
so
so now it's interesting to consider how
might we use the hardware um to speed up
some of this stuff um well first like
let's think about like what's slow here
right
so cpu rendering takes a lot of time
that's what we're just doing just in
software just filling in those pixels
right as we know them um
that's a ton of operations right the
second part was it's really expensive to
eventually take that product and push it
over to the gpu that's just like copies
are really expensive to go to the gpu so
we want to minimize those things all
together right
so
luckily uh if you look at any like
graphics hardware you always see like
there's some sort of amount of you know
megabytes that the card has well that's
it's gpu's memory right so so what's the
point of this memory like how could we
use this here well if you think back to
our process of doing you know the
drawing and the layers and then
compositing step
that compositing step had a bunch of
these just chunks of memory these layers
that we've generated and they're not
really changing they're kind of just
there
so what if we instead copy them over to
the gpu's memory
so we say hey jp gpu hold on to these
right we've just drawn these cool so we
draw them once and give them to them and
then uh
and then so all we need at this point um
to
to basically finish the process is if we
just had a way to tell the gpu hey uh
take these layers right and squish them
together because um
that's like the last step right well
luckily this is exactly what gpu is
designed to do incredibly well right so
these textures that we have on the gpu
the gpu acts like a compositor for us
because we give them the simple
lightweight commands uh on any given
frame that we're drawing to make like
say our animation around the screen or
scrolling we're saying hey take those
layers and rearrange like recomposite
that that pink one to be on the blue one
in this next location next location next
location that kind of communication is
really fast copying those frames every
time not fast so this is something that
the gpu is designed for
it's a great sandwich maker
and this is basically yeah this is
basically um
this is accelerated compositing this is
exactly what we do in webkit this is the
process so
back to translate z right
so what's going on here with translate z
well um it's doing exactly this it's
kicking us into a mode where we start
doing
it in the in the second fashion we start
allocating these layers for things that
you translate zeon um because we we
can't afford to not um handle this 3d
case where we need to do it or else it's
just incredibly slow so we jump into
compositing mode we start allocating
layers so those things you give
translate z to which means that they
also start to have all this extra memory
right so this is kind of like the it's
like the be careful message right this
is where you're walking with a really
heavy stick when you start translating z
on everything um but of course you can
get really fast speed ups if you're
doing the kind of thing that would
basically be draw once in a layer and
move it around the page because that
hardware compositing is what works
really fast right in this mode
cool so let's go back to our example
and use a little thing called webkit
debug borders to check out what's going
on in our example when we added
translate c
so those words are falling really sweet
from the top and so now we see um
we see that like every single word has
this uh debug border around it um now
i'm not gonna go into too much detail
about this but this is basically a
little debug mode that we have in webkit
to look at um which elements on the page
are
actually getting these layers so they're
so they're actually getting memory
assigned to them that they get to draw
into that's reserved for just them and
then is also backed by gpu memory right
that we that we use in order to do this
accelerated compositing last step
so obviously you can see there's like
plenty of things in the page that are
getting these these little green boxes
however we're doing this well because
we're not over using them there's
nothing in the page that's like getting
these layers that doesn't need it to
like all the words in the background for
example
so
this is a perfect example of how to use
it correctly
and um
yeah so
by the end of the talk here um and so
just as like one more point right as if
i guess uh for fun if you
if you consider like uh ways to minimize
the usage of it use it just for the kind
of cases where you're doing those things
that would would benefit from uh
accelerating accelerating the
compositing and you can even get like
really nice effects like this in a page
so we kind of made a different version
of the game where
we're just really taxing a lot of things
being moved around
and we have
a little bit of time left um
so so yeah so that was a quick run
through of how accelerated compositing
works in webkit and
how rendering in general works in a in a
browser
does anyone have any questions
so uh
the other browsers
don't have this problem
why does webkit have this problem where
they need to create new layers for every
hardware accelerated thing which problem
the the
the other browsers like have one layer
and they hardware accelerate everything
on that at least according to their tech
docs well right um they may be
accelerating like the actual like body
that all the time
which essentially is kind of always the
case because you always need to have
some sort of reserved chunk of memory
that you eventually draw into the idea
is if you are
using
intermediary
chunks of memory right like little
buffers along the way to do part of the
drawing into um which anyone does when
they're doing this compositing right um
it's when you choose to do it is perhaps
what's interesting um so something webk
is a problem it's it's the thing that
solves the problem of doing it faster
um
yeah that makes any sense
so you showed the example where you're
accidentally triggering the whole reflow
in the loop
um how can you how can you tell that
you're doing that or
how can you
is this sort of
way to see that that's happening you
know all you can see is the performance
sucks but right yeah um
so so of course you can always like um
try to be cognizant of that but at the
end of the day like when you're
debugging the the biggest tip is to go
into the um into the web inspector uh
and look at um timelines if you want to
talk about this a bit yeah um so in the
web inspector you can look at the
timeline of layout and rendering and
when you're triggering all this reflow
what you can see is a lot of like relay
out relay layout layout in between two
renders so you really ideally only want
to do one relay out before one render
another good way for this specific case
is that you can actually find this
online i think several people have
talked about it or blogged about it they
listed all the values that would trigger
this three layout
and they're called computer values in
webkit and if you look for the earlier
function i show like update layout
ignoring blah blah blah blah if you
search for that then that pretty much
lists out everything that you need to be
cognizant of not using too much
all right i think we're out of time uh
we're gonna have a break now and uh come
back in 10 minutes so
thank you guys